hey everyone Game of Thrones final
season is getting closer and closer with
the main cast members finally having
wrapped production in the whole series
and a few possible clues about the new
season are starting to come out guys
it's been too long since we've discussed
Game of Thrones here new rock star so in
this episode we're gonna talk all about
it but first welcome to new rock start
snoozer deep-diving all the biggest
stories this week so we're also gonna
talk about the Black Widow movies new
director all the latest details on
Shazam and Lando Calrissian being in
Star Wars Episode nine America watching
me at the super worst and back for
Phillip Alina DJ Wooldridge doing great
it's hot as hell again but not as much
as last time last time I'm gonna be
sweating still just for you guys he can
control let's get start with our top
story
Game of Thrones Season 8 and all the new
details that we now know about it
now this time exactly one year ago
remember we were completely swamped with
our coverage of Game of Thrones Season
seven but the show was taking a full
year off to produce its final season
with season 8 not returning until 2019
we don't have an exact release date yet
it's looking like it'll be spring maybe
around May June my sources
I don't know now details about season 8
have been kept tightly under wraps with
scripts that self-destruct on iPads
after scenes have been shot but many
people died yeah no survivors um in
either the narrative or yes but here are
some new updates now that the season has
wrapped okay and spoiler warning if you
don't want to know stuff but why don't
you click on the video yo okay Maisie
Williams who plays Arya Stark
instagrammed a goodbye photo that showed
her shoes covered in blood with the
hashtags last woman standing
and barely now that could've heard
earlier be maybe the last actress to
finish shooting on the show or perhaps
that she'll be the last female character
left alive on this show we'll see also
sophie turner play slots historic
promised a bloodier season with more
death and emotional torture in which
we'll see everyone coming together to
fight against inwards you know the
impending doom of what you know could be
the I don't want to give to way away too
much anyway a big threat no those are
her words clearly a foot-and-mouth there
there are some rumors about her surprise
pregnancy twists thank you
two months back based on a TV line post
that didn't name Game of Thrones
specifically remember Cersei did tell
Jaime that she was pregnant last season
though there were some speculation that
she could been lying to manipulate him
so if this rumor is true we could be
looking at like a Denarius pregnancy we
have to be yeah we got to crazy earlier
this year there were some social media
photos near Belfast reporting a large
fire on the Game of Thrones set that
someone speculated could be the castle
of Winterfell burning to the ground lot
of the people who like hang around the
set of like oh that's normally where
Winterfell is and then not too long ago
actor Joe Dempsey who plays ginjury
talked about his expanded role in season
8 meaning Gendry survived the night King
and vissarion's destruction of the wall
he also mentioned shooting scenes with
Kit Harington and Alfie Allen suggesting
that the ungrate Julie could return to
Winterfell piece enough of this stuff
together you can start to figure out
what might happen and then finally Jason
Momoa has shown up in a lot of candid
photos with other cast members
suggesting that maybe Khal Drogo could
make some kind of return maybe in
another dream sequence for Daenerys or
maybe Aquaman just wants to hang out I
hope he's still like Oh like dead behind
the eyes and like just dumb he's the
night's king now we're less than a year
away from the final season hopefully and
let's make some predictions name I'm
curious for you guys I want to know a
plot twist that you think will end up
being the most shocking moment of this
final season all the cast members are
saying will be the shocking this yet or
and also one crazy theory that may be in
your heart of hearts as fans you just
want to see happen even though it
probably won't you go really excited I'm
playing in a visible keyboard oh I'm
just holding down just dramatic notes
parks and recs fans it sounded like you
remember the fake company they make
something 720 to give out under 70 when
they give out the iPads like candy
they're like stop giving out it sounds
like that scenario
I don't want Danny to have a baby I
don't like how normal incest is in this
show they're like world it's like I'm
like it's still a part of this show that
I'm like laughs you taught us that beat
well
test that's enough yeah right that
that's not incest is it who is it
yes know what that means either
okay just take on the question plot
twist that I think it could happen would
shock everyone who is that Danny is bad
and they'd have to kill Danny right that
would be a real shocking thought to us
that they were kind of building toward
impossible anyway one crazy theory that
I want my inner child once happen is not
that it's that Danny is as or high and
that she needs to kill John that that's
the opposite of the other I mean that
crazy that that actually sounds more
plausible to me that like they're
working toward her being some kind of
being the prophesied figure right I mean
there's kind of debate over whether it's
John or Danny
yeah or maybe both and maybe or maybe
prophecies are bad maybe no listen to
him Star Wars taught me that I wanted
the dragon versus dragon fight I think
that'd be pretty cool to be cool to see
I could dragon crash and track down a
kingdom that could be or like a castle
that could be very cool as well
Theon I feel like he's gone through so
much and he's burned so many people I
just I'd be fine if he just went away
just like oh I know we feel bad for
because he's bought we went through
horrible things but it's like at certain
points like just wow go away please just
be nice to that person if he comes back
awesome what did like robot parts and
cars like he's just like amazing team I
know the fun reveal was like Danny and
John are related so and tyrion tyrion is
listening and we're like we're all but
it would have fun twist no no one's
actually related we can go ahead and
move on past that but actual theory that
I think could be fun is a final showdown
oh wait no this is fun twists say your
idea anyway you that was me thinking
okay no I was just thinking that it
would be cool to see
Cersei team up with them and I don't
know how I would want that twist to
happen you said Danny turning into like
a villain for the season could be
interesting to see her take out searcy
and it would be really it would be a lot
of complicated motions because most
people be like her Eames like she's
awful but they
I don't know they'd be interesting I
think twist that would really devastate
people if they're like you know what
guys we're gonna wait till george RR
martin finishes the books before you get
the final season be pretty and then
whenever we don't we've shot it it's
edited but where it's gonna sit in the
can somewhere until george RR martin
finishes the book cuz he had a cameo yet
in the show that seems like a massage
well yeah he had a glamour spell i don't
know if you saw what is gorgeous so he
is the baby of Danny and John boom but
he comes out like george RR martin you
get a shot flash forward or flash
sideways lost fancy you know i'm talking
about and then you can get and it's him
in present-day and you're like how has
he been ill how is he here he's like
he's writing a biography of his family's
life he's telling a story about his past
and that the game of thrones world is
real the unlikely twists i don't see
that happening I'd like to see that I
don't think what happened is kind of a
long long Sam spline because I do like
John and Danny together the real is
Danny's not actually so I don't know
that they're not that she's not alone
yeah cuz I am a fan of that coupling and
I want to keep being a fan of it not
about the ickey I know I'm over at this
point they're hoping that we've been
desensitized and and every like group of
friends who watch Game of Thrones next
season that anytime John and Danny are
like romantic could be like that his
aunt yes her nephew like it's not we
remember it's tough because they're
young and pretty and so you're you want
to be okay with it and they're cool with
their characters we like and they've got
good chemistry but they're also related
they attach that logic to realize it's
like if they're pretty enough they could
do what they can go ahead I don't like
Aunt Nicole Eric what are you oh my what
I think will be the craziest twist well
I think we're gonna be like surprised on
what the big threat of the final cuz I
keep like trying to read between the
lines of Sophie Turner's quote and she
kept saying like
the she mentioned word doom and that
just reminds me of like the creative
yeah you know which was this mysterious
national calamity of volcanoes or
meteors they aren't really sure exactly
what happened but I'm thinking there's
gonna be some other kind of natural
disaster that's not like winter in a way
that they have to worry about and they
have to like it'd be good to out of it
when it gets worse they take out the
Nights Watch episode one like oh cool
that actually wasn't too bad or the
night the night king's army yeah I'm
sorry the White Walkers
oh no problem that was that was actually
like oh I took out the Nights Watch how
about you pull of Parks and Rec can you
go three years in the future and you're
like but what happened like what yeah
what happens oh you remember and you get
like 15 minutes an episode of like they
do like one 16 second flashback and it's
the most expensive 16 seconds on TV ever
it's just it's like one a big comic
splash panel of like everything like
remember that the flash that's how I Met
Your Mother and then other like upset
fans like rillette at that verse yeah I
mean do we think Arya is going to be the
last woman standing let's just address
that the shoes that are bloodied or not
they're just tennis shoes which is the
biggest twist maybe West world crossover
this is all the stuff is when the park
is going crazy guys everyone I asked
this question by the way so all of this
is your fault
these are unlikely twists well now that
we know there is a link between West's
world and Game of Thrones in the finale
of West's world there was an astrolabe
in the library that's the exact one
that's in the old town library at the
beginning and there are unrevealed
worlds in West world right there's three
more that we don't know one of them
could be a Game of Thrones
weird twist that would be like you see
like one of the samurai or the cowboy
show up it seems like I got
reinforcements why are there animatronic
dragons in this park
there better be this got really
and one turned into theirs it reminded
me of like senior tennis shoes like in
Star Wars peter cushing more like his
slippers and he just demanded the George
Lucas shoot him from the waist up like I
will only be in yeah I don't know I
don't think she would say last woman
standing and had that like she's smart
enough she's social media savvy I don't
agree I think she slipped up I think she
liked it like she's gonna be the last
woman standing I think she said it
totally happened with what's-her-face
Kate from lost Livelinks yeah she did
one Instagram
oh she's spoiled oh and she's credit no
she spoiled who the like was a surprise
for real villain and oh she said Goliath
hey you guys could have come to America
and watch that movie earlier all right
if you really care what we don't go by
the facts I gave you about the World Cup
last week Maude what's your take
[Laughter]
that's true and you know having aria
being the last woman's aria I guess some
people come there's no II in there I
guess it's Aria are you yeah i mean
george RR martin did say she was one of
like the five or six characters he
imagined being there at the end of the
story at the end of the books at least
who knows if the books will end up going
differently than the show well that's
what I hope that's why I hope it's like
the biggest twist of all this is that
the show just ends one way in Georgia
our barn is like okay I got like three
or four more years to write out the rest
of these and I'm gonna go in a
completely collaboration that's gonna
happen first of all he cuz he he kind of
said almost like that he was going to
adjust some things but I if I want to
make a prediction real quick I think
that the show is gonna change the way it
ends a little bit because of the
prequels that are in production where
they're gonna want there to be some
setup
so there's a nice handoff to those
prequels so I wouldn't be surprised if
we actually don't get every answer we
expect and every kind of closure so that
they can kind of be like we got to watch
the prequels for that and we will be
talking about the prequels in a bit so
it's like that one scene this is deep
cut for all you that one scene in
Sicario to where it's like oh so you
also want to be in Sicario three-week
franchise I didn't see scenario two are
they seriously building the Sicari it's
not bad it's not bad in your face but
there's there's a seat there's a scene
in the movie that it's like Oh Tony's
definitely trying to make this like a
thing that's the first one that God did
so well uh but but I kind of I think
George RR Martin's waiting it could be
one of two things George Martin
desperately doesn't want to finish the
books or two he's waiting to see how
people react to the ending so he can
gauge like maybe don't do that maybe I
do do that you know what I mean so he
can I don't know yeah no that's that's I
mean he isn't an interesting position
where he can have this like TV show like
as an author he isn't I have to just
like throw you know shooting to the dark
right now and see how things go and an
adjuster or maybe flesh out certain
things that people are confused about he
can give it another chapter to the point
of view chapter to somebody but I liked
I liked how closely the earlier seasons
Hugh towards the books and I'm kind of
bummed that we're not gonna get
something the whole show is not gonna be
able to be that tight as those first
like three to four seasons were you know
I mean because because of that stuff it
would have been it way I'd be interested
like in some sort of alternate reality
where they were able to do the show
after the books were done so you like
the whole show was able to be as tight
as those first few seasons yeah or they
could just like pick and choose which
storylines to do as opposed to just kind
of like because because the tone of the
show did change after they went to I
think if they kind of known more it's
like maybe we wouldn't have spent two
seasons with Ramsey torturing Theon like
maybe we would have liked you a lot of
that time elsewhere you know yeah they
kind of matched what level of detail he
was going into and not knowing that like
oh we're not gonna pay that off well you
kind of get a sense I loved season seven
by the way but you kind of got a sense
that like there was a little bit of
stretching in five and six and then
seven was like oh we got a hurry you
know I mean so yeah that's why I'm a
little like I not thrown but like I
actually think season 8 is gonna be
crazy tight in
that it's going to be too tight because
they're like we don't have room to do
anything but these five things and that
there's actually gonna be a lot that is
left out completely but they talked
about how they work on structuring
they're more like movies like each
episode was a movie so I do have faith
in that they can if they kind of go with
that structure they can take some stuff
out or maybe not spend as much time as
they normally would with a season but
you'd still have the time to you could
start a few new stories but mainly kind
of bring everything back round to an end
I don't know what kind of ending I would
want exactly out of this like it the
final note what you leave on is like
isn't the end of the battle is it like a
look off into the sunset I'm not sure
aliens would be a great twist yeah and
let us know what you think of these
theories aliens only the alien in the
comments below or you can tweet us at
new rock stars or at each of our
individual handles and yeah let us know
what you have what's your craziest
prediction for the final season of Game
of Thrones both what you think will it
be the shocking most shocking moment and
what you think is most unlikely but what
you who are dying as he happen then
screenshot your comment save it on your
desktop and then tweet it at us in a
year or whenever when we actually see it
and rub it in our faces and maybe we'll
send you a prize I won't stand by that
but you have to promise that Phillip
will do that yeah we'll be talking more
about like especially those Game of
Thrones prequels in a bit let's move on
to this week's trivia question oh I'm so
bad at this okay our trivia question in
Game of Thrones Jon Snow's legitimacy as
heir to the Iron Throne as official son
of Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark
was confirmed in a record of Rhaegar
annulment by a High Septon what was that
septons name okay another quick news
update from this week guys the upcoming
Black Widow movie has an official
director Kate Shortland a chitlin was
chosen by Kevin Feige from a field of
like forty nine candidates Shortland is
an Australian director known for smaller
award-winning films lore and Berlin
Syndrome if people happen to see those
Lorde actually took place in the
aftermath of world war two so Shortland
has experience with film set and past
two historical periods suggesting we
could be seeing a black widow origin
story set in time in Natasha's past as
the KGB agent
if Shortland chooses to go in that
direction very somebody would steal what
Cisco Johansson's part to play that yeah
yeah yeah they can use that da gene
technology we're gonna use D aging tech
on Samuel Jackson and Captain Marvel
looks like what he looks the same way
put a wig on him and we'd all be fine
she shot this during Batman Returns okay
Laurence Fishburne though just one
little thing it was when he they did the
aging for him for a second there's a
second where it looks like he's being
born just like the only thing I got was
Laurence Fishburne is that I think his
head got bigger
if since he's become older they didn't
do big it it wasn't whisper it was his
son it was Langston Fishburne right his
son who looks exactly like it's almost
like Ice Cube son and yeah and Rita
Compton looks it looks he's like see I
got my dad's thing from the major I just
I just I just watched the matrix again
recently and it's crazy how babyface
Laurence Fishburne in that movie then
watch Apocalypse Now didn't know and
then Keanu Reeves looks exactly the same
okay everyone more big Game of Thrones
news came out this week with reports
about a second game of Thrones prequel
series officially in the works now we
had already gotten reports not long ago
about won Game of Thrones prequels
series produced by George are Martin and
Ryder Jane Goldman it'll take that one
will take place a thousand years before
the current events it but in the Age of
Heroes and I'll explore more of the
mystery the White Walkers and the pilot
of that first one will begin shooting in
October so it's coming it's coming soon
but the second series is going under the
working title Empire of ashes and it
will tell the story of the doom of
Valyria now in the backstory of the Song
of Ice and Fire series Valyria is like
the ancient empire that was mysteriously
destroyed and some natural disaster
event that's called the doom of Valyria
some people say it's a volcanic eruption
or meteors it's not really clear it's a
mystery it's kind of like Atlantis or
Pompeii if we didn't know it just
but there is a creepy poem about it
that's worth reading it's in the books
the hills that split asunder and the
black that ate the skies the flames that
shot so high and hot that even dragons
burned the city of a thousand years and
all that men had learned that doom
consumed them all alike and neither of
them turned neither a time turn I don't
know you really Johnny didn't in Game of
Thrones we actually briefly saw the
ruins of Valyria when Tyrion Lannister
and surge or Mormont voted through it
remember that was the time when Jorah
got infected with greyscale plaque
psoriasis now Empire of ashes will also
tell the story of the origins of House
Targaryen the it was a minor family of
the Dragonlords and old Valyria who rose
to prominence by fleeing to Westeros
just before the doom leading them with
the world's only living dragons a
description from this from this release
yeah we have these super proud Targaryen
now but there was a time when the
Targaryens were kind of like a little
[ __ ] family yeah there were runaways
refugees I mean literally they became
yeah because they were the first to like
run they survived yeah and it's the only
reason yeah and they retained some of
that culture so imagine like the people
who it when Rome collapse and the Roman
Empire just kind of went away that
people who like retain that culture in
that technology or yeah kind of a blast
men and women stand that's the story
behind super mario romans we said
runaways that made me think of who lose
runaways Marvel property run away with a
dinosaur similar to dragon doesn't mean
la is gonna fall we'll find out next
season Runaways and game well what's
interesting is we have two prequel
series right there's one exploring the
origins of the White Walkers one
exploiting the origins of the dragons it
seems like we have a choice between ice
and fire if we have two series ones like
they should just call it ice and fire
like the rides that adventure in Florida
between the two of these which are you
guys more excited to binge and dig more
into and I need to be down for I mean
dragons are always gonna be fun
but the White Walkers are pretty more
are gonna be more interesting for me us
I'll say that I'm bored with that but I
think also because in the books there's
a lot about that Age of Heroes and like
there's so many questions that are
unanswered and there's huge decisions
that are having to be made and then the
Targaryen family line like is definitely
a really complicated family drama series
so in terms of Game of Thrones like I'm
more excited about the other one but in
terms of that show that's on HBO right
now that's like about this family that
is like very Shakespearean succession I
could see a version of that being a
really fascinating character to take and
the cool thing for you Sam about the
dragon one is there's gonna be a lot of
incest on that one which I know is your
favorite part of the show I always love
it when you have like these genre these
genre properties that have like a deep
mythology that is it really like there's
a lot of mystery to it and then they
love to just dive in like hey let's take
all the mystery away because that's
always what people want and it's not
anyway it's it takes some of the fun cuz
it's never as cool as you imagined I
thought as you were talking about that
it'd be really interesting if they
treated these spin-offs as almost like
an anthology so like season one is Age
of Heroes season two is the Targaryen
family if there is a season three like
each seasons another part of the of the
mythology that's a bit of a Robert's
rebellion yeah it's kind of like you
don't have to because after the doom of
Valyria well then my point there's not a
story existing there yeah so they're
gonna have to invent like one sentence
about each generation yeah and so then
if you if you did like an anthology
thing it gives you an opportunity to
like hit the highlights but not
necessarily have to build out something
that's supposed to be as rich and
compete with the Game of Thrones itself
and what's more interesting if you the
doom of Valyria do you have three
seasons of it the doom not happening and
then it's coming and you're like we got
to stop it but we know that
realistically we want that to happen in
the pilot because then you you really
want to talk about see aftermath imagine
like it's like it's a fall of Krypton at
the beginning and the story is what
happens when they leave and under the
red Sun of Westeros if the pace is slow
then like let's not have a huge slow
build-up to the doom but true yeah I
feel like you could criticize both
directions you go like one seasons like
okay that I think
like one season in valeri you know
things gonna come maybe somebody knows
because of course if somebody's gonna
know when the big decides to show
Krypton mm-hmm and then you have and
then you have the next season they
dealing with a doom but it's also part
of the heal of doctor didn't the
storytelling the part of the people of
the doom is the mystery behind it like
if you're like oh it's okay knows oh
it's underwhelming like I mean I've
always been pretty much assumed is all
okay I don't want to be is that what is
that what is the doom what messed up the
seasons there was an event that kind of
messed up the seasons in the Game of
Thrones world which is why they take
generations as opposed to months why
winter laughs for like years was that
was about there I'm distance from there
son okay there's there's all these kind
of mysteries whether it's like this just
magical world where but there have been
some like astrophysicists which charted
out different orbital paths that make it
make sense they said if it's part of a
trinary star system that it could smear
it's one of the how game Thrones kind of
hooked me initially because it started
off like you you right off the bat you
had the scene with the White Walkers in
the woods so you knew okay there's a
little supernatural here but otherwise
it was a political drama set in medieval
times and like you only had little
things like the fact that seasons took
which I it wasn't till I kept assault
for that I had finally absorbed enough
to be like Oh seasons aren't there
seasons are are seasons well look at the
people that watch full season one and
they're like is this not England I
watched I was not paying attention I'm
like this is just like England and
Scotland and oh my god I don't remember
a big ice wall and yes it happens and
now seasons later we've earned now it's
a straight up Lord of the Rings esque
fantasy epic and it's earned that you're
and I mean it's earned the ability to
have you know the kind of some of the
shortcuts that it's taken in seven
seasons like I don't know I'm a little
like I feel I'm feel like this the
spin-offs can't help but be lesser
compared to the main thing like kind of
like I have almost zero interest in the
Lord of the Rings show maybe but how
much interest do you have in Marvel as a
cinematic
per day going into various stories
meeting up together for other stories it
depends on how the good the story is
which some people believe that starting
to see them actually yeah it's hard to
imagine what this spin-off would look
like until you actually see it like I
love the show better call Saul I love
Breaking Bad even more than that it's
like I never would have thought at the
outset that you could do a complete five
season series about just Saul Goodman
but it's riveting yeah so the story is
the key can they tell a good story I
think one smart thing to do is don't
tell the same kind of story in both
wonder-percent because that's going to
the better call Saul example that's it's
a very different show and I also I think
better call Saul is a great example too
because it uses the clout that Breaking
Bad got it to do something they if you
just pitch that show cult it would have
never gotten made but with Breaking Bad
behind it they'd be like yeah and you
want to take like it's so procedural it
takes so much time with just little
details like when Mike's like trailing
somebody using like a baby monitor yeah
in like it and so these Game of Thrones
spin-offs are able to use like use the
Game of Thrones name to tell fantasy
stories that no they would never be
allowed to do otherwise interesting yeah
yeah so obviously I am the question for
you guys is gonna be which one do you
guys are you guys more excited about but
I have a bonus question on that do you
think that this idea about AT&T
purchasing H HBO and got a goddamn vamp
the idea of them purchasing HBO means
that they're not gonna have the ability
to dedicate as much budget oh my god
it's all over my pants anymore it's
getting in the wires
oh the ant farm under the table it's
getting into Phillips wires yes so do
you think AT&T is going to prevent HBO
from dedicating budget let us know in
the comments below
someone's bleeding that's selling a joke
really got
guys I need to hydrate
thank God so the question for you the
the question was 18 she buying buying
HBO well there is a news report of the
new Bosco and HBO like it's gonna be a
hard year because we've got to churn out
like three times the content because
Netflix it mix it and it was like it was
like I don't know about you guys but
like reading that it was like really
depressing cuz it's like I like the way
HBO turns out kinda yeah this is more
like it turns out less but it is it is
the best content out there barring an FX
maybe you're gonna mean like yeah but
another quick news update from this week
mornings from Star Wars Episode nine
Billy Dee Williams who played the
original Lando Calrissian in the Empire
Strikes Back and Return of the Jedi will
be returning for Episode nine
now some fans we're hoping that he would
return since you know all the other big
players from the original trilogy have
appeared in the new movies Williams will
be joining Keri Russell who will also be
playing a big role in Episode Billy Dee
Williams will be playing r2d2 okay
everyone we've been getting some news
about the upcoming Shazam movie this
week with an official photo from the
movie showing Zach Levi in costume and
the director David Sandberg announced
that we will be seeing a trailer for the
movie at Comic Con next week so here's
just you know a primer of everything you
need to know about Shazam before you see
this trailer so you don't feel like a
dumb-dumb okay he's a classic superhero
from the DC Comics he's the alter ego of
a boy named Billy Batson Billy speaks
the magic word Shazam which is an
acronym of the six immortal elders
Solomon Hercules Atlas Zeus Achilles and
Mercury and then he transforms into the
adult superhero with similar powers to
Superman now originally the adult
superhero was named Captain Marvel but
Marvel Comics released their own version
of a character named Captain Marvel or
Marvel so the DC version just eventually
started to go by Shazam to avoid
confusion but he goes by both names in
this one they're probably just gonna
calm Shazam now one of Shazam's primary
nemesis is Black Adam who has Dwayne
there
Johnson attached to play him though
black Adam will not appear in this movie
he hopefully will get his own movie
coming ups no cameo either confirmed
right now they have announced that John
on han-soo will be playing the wizard
and not to confuse you too much but the
Wizards name I think what Shazam right
but he's just being called the wizard
and later comics he's just known as the
wizard he's the 3000 year old being
who's seeking a successor and he's the
one who gives Billy his powers
now she's aim is marketing itself as
kind of a wish fulfillment superhero
movie with a similar tone to the movie
big with Tom Hanks perfect rage such a
good pitch for me so what do you guys
see Shazam bringing to the DC movie
universe that isn't there I mean
lightness right yeah look at from this
is actually from if you guys want a good
just a quick sum up of Shazam with a
really good story that's probably gonna
be what the movie is it's Jeff Johnson
Gary Frank did a Shazam story like four
years ago five years ago 52 it's really
good it's really pretty and if you guys
want just like a fun story and it's the
same thing that exact scene is from the
comic where he saves somebody like oh do
you want something they get soda and
they get the drink again he's a kid
also I found out why they have the
Lightning so small because usually it
goes all the way down his body and so he
can bend his oh yeah bend his body in
any direction so that's why it's only
right here like right this is a more
updated version of the costume too they
previously had slight differences on it
um I think I like that Shazam more
recently has been kind of a comedic
figure they like realize what a fun idea
it is to put a child's brain in this
man's body yeah and I think that they
played that up a lot in the depictions
it like even the animated series when he
shows up he's just like a funnier
character the original versions of that
were like this real weird experience for
me where I was just like why does I
couldn't get why the character even
existed honestly yeah it was a moment
way back in the day that he was moving
when he was first introduced he's more
popular than Superman we are a long way
away from that now but this could be a
cool opportunity for DC to kind of do
like equal but opposite Deadpool
something that kind of like is an
irreverent version of the super story
we're used to but in a more lighthearted
kid-friendly way than Deadpool right
like give Ferris Bueller superpowers or
some
that's a great way to pitch this - yeah
and it's in Captain Marvel Shazam was
always kind of confusing because I think
and it probably when you and I were
growing up it was more like the classic
comic for situation where Shazam was
actually a different person than Billie
was and yes like like why is this exist
then why do we need the Billie part yeah
like like Thor in the Congress used to
be Donald Blake and then he his thing
and then he became four so it's like
well then why is Donald Blake they're
like what's anyway yeah this is fine all
right but now it's time to move on to
our new rock stars news lightning
Phillip at iron quill wants to know what
is your spirit animal any dog yep oh
yeah Sam at true score and wants to know
Sam first crush on a fictional character
nah I just remember first crush period
with Britney Spears so in love
I think first fixable yeah I was like in
first crush ever first question is
Britney Spears but a fictional is pay
mayonnaise from Doug yeah small
gentleman wants to know small gentleman
wants to know what movies do the best
job at incorporating music what like
what genres may be what specific movies
come to mind when you think of like they
did a really good job in corporate
soundtrack the best movie soundtrack
that you can good call sorry baby
drivers hard to top it did such a great
job incorporating its music any
Tarantino film Sam's giving me a look
it's fine that's fine yeah it has good
music in it baby drivers the objective
because they actually like wrote the
essentially even though it doesn't
function like we typically understand
musicals to function it is essentially
musical yes and yes so it's just it's
hard to it's hard to top that but turn
team is always a really good at
incorporating music I feel like there's
one I'm missing
[Music]
Hado underscore underscore potato potato
potato for Eric what would you do if you
were a kid and you had to Sam's powers
to turn into an adult for one day so
you're a kid but you can become an adult
for one day what would you do I would he
has more power go by the letter the of
the question I would go see an r-rated
movie yeah for sure cause I was afraid
to do that as a kid you know they don't
always care and I would I would probably
I would buy a lot of candy I probably
wouldn't just go buy alcohol because I
don't I still buy bags of candy yeah as
I feel like that would ya just fast
forwarding directly to that not having a
wait time to be the man I am now the
question also sounds like it's phrase
like a purge night question like if you
were a tad out first like yeah whatever
you want it's like you can what would
you do lightning close thank you hate oh
potato it was a pleasure and true
scoring small gentlemen and iron
something you guys are great and all the
people you guys are in those of you who
didn't get to thank you for tweeting us
and look out for a tweet next week and
we love interacting with you and just
tweet us often we'll just respond
sometimes I'll just respond to your
question someone wanted me to the
Jurassic Park Raptor growl and I just I
did it because I felt like doing it at
the time so you don't have to wait for
lightning round tweet us really good
some person keeps asking about my hair
just a hair dryer okay well next up let
us take a look at what we got in the
pipeline for videos coming out on this
channel in the pipeline in the pipeline
hey dig alright
okay we have our dye our breakdown
series that we're doing of the Dark
Knight trilogy by personal and we just
uploaded Batman Begins thank you for all
the positive feedback on that spread it
around so people can see this because I
mean if these videos do what we'd love
to do this kind of project the future
but the Dark Knight is the the you know
the big tamale of that one it's coming
out on Wednesday July 18th which is the
10-year anniversary of the movie so
we're very very excited about it we put
a lot of work into this our editors are
working around the clock to make this
one a real special one for you guys and
then a week after that we have our
breakdown of the Dark Knight Rises which
I'm currently in the weeds and right now
and you know it's a much better movie to
remember I remember liking it but like
over the years some people like you
started to be critical of it forget that
it's it's a much better movie I'm an
older film there's so much so we're
gonna get to all the reasons why it's a
really good movie so keep an eye out for
that one as well and then at the end of
next week is Comic Con so it sounds like
we will have an Aquaman trailer and it's
exam trailer maybe also trailers for
fantastic beast crimes of Grindelwald
and a Wonder Woman 1984 so whatever big
trailers come out of that we will be
working a dressing out to try to give
this to you as well so lots of lots of
good stuff in the pipeline from new rock
stars and we'll see if Captain Marvel
trailer coming out soon hey but maybe
venom spider-man into the spider version
oh yeah all kinds of yeah so yeah keep
an eye out on this channel and as always
if you haven't subscribed yet subscribe
right because it's gonna be it's gonna
be a great month coming ahead so now
comes the time for a 15-second shout
outs where each of us is 15 seconds to
shout out plug or ramble about anything
we want Sam why don't you start queer I
Netflix I don't need to say more if you
want if you want a show yeah genuine
shoot day that genuinely just makes your
life just a little bit better clear I
yeah yeah it's great it's really really
good for my dad on the add my shout out
is for the HBO series sharp objects
which is a written it was a book written
by Gillian Flynn the same person who did
gone girl both the movie
in the book it's got Amy Adams it's
great it's a little slow but if you like
like patient small-town crime dramas
that like have really interesting
editing and amazing acting check it out
I say watch blockers it's a better
comedy than it should be don't have huge
expectations for it but John Cena's
really funny in it and the kids are
really funny in it okay we should talk
about we should do a breakdown of it oh
sure yeah it's just it's just every once
in a while we get a slightly better
terrible movie you know what I mean like
those movies come out all the time but
that one has like some really fun
moments with John Cena the knockoff
Wahlberg in that movie I like him use
funny John Cena the other one oh I bear
Holtz yeah so for me last time ever that
you'll hear about this here chaos theory
comic calm hot dang there's only a
couple days left we've it's funded it's
happening it's now we are working on our
first stretch goal which were actually
really close to and on that stretch goal
that boy over there is going to write
and draw his own 30 page comic and draw
it'll be digitally banned from writing
or drawing anything yeah now now he's
gonna write and draw and also no matter
what tear oh my goodness not no matter
what tear you choose you will be getting
that digital comic if we reach our
stretch goal so go to chaos theory comic
calm for more on that it's got zombies
it's got dinosaurs it's got aliens it's
got everything you and I and all of us
here love it's gonna have variant covers
to my comic and that's maybe my my own
pocket it's gonna be something special
oh like the Batman Forever mugs I think
they'll break in churches it's digital
so they can't Sam spitballing about
where he's going with this I think like
a religion is gonna spin out of this
thing and it's not gonna be good or
it'll be amazing
well isn't that the greatest testament
written and drawn by Sam basher what
happens after revelations check it out
yeah yeah he's down on his look let's
return to our trivia question that we
asked earlier also that you what we just
did here you'll be able to vote on the
setting and the plot and everything too
so it'll be similar to what just
happened right now he'll find a way to
row this was a really really tough one
in Game of Thrones Jon Snow's legitimacy
is heir to Iron Throne
the official son of Rhaegar and Lyanna
was confirmed in a record of regards
annulment by a High Septon what was the
septons name what did we write down DJ
Septon Churchill okay Sam Rhodes related
to Odin or hey or are like martín or
Martin yeah cuz it's an in yay
Alistair which I know he's referencing
Aleister Crowley because Eric I got fill
bro Oh something with something no M
something M something because it is High
Septon Maynard ma Y n AR D so M will
Emma's clothes pretty sure only one
person wrote ceptin in it these are
three names there's lots of different
ways we could be wrong judges who's the
closest yeah
yay cuz I wrote em something judges
who's the farthest where's it I'm not
gonna look like Samuel I don't know what
a sham alright so Philip we'll do our
goodbyes
Sam unfortunately one have to or
fortunately for us well we have to do
are in other news headlines that we did
not have time for
I'll read each headline and then Sam
will have to make a joke at the end of
the headline and cleverly riff on it
are we ready Sam well you can do it just
remember Sam's been taking improv
classes for this exact purpose yes and
here we go in other news Marblehead
Kevin Feige confirmed that half of all
life was wiped away in thanasis nap
including animals wait and for podcast
listeners we have not gone dark this is
a great bit hey hopefully it means half
the calories am i right all right
the joaquin phoenix joker origin movie
is moving forward and is rumored to
feature Bruce Wayne's father
what yeah I ain't no laughing matter
yeah good Avengers director left your
bag of applause for Avengers director
Joss Whedon is developing an HBO series
called the Nevers about a gang of
Victorian women with unusual abilities
ah
you know it's almost there I never he's
never gonna get my views ever again for
making this know from other stuff he
said you got bad you got a bad talk
didn't oh wait I got another one
you've been drinking or you know some I
had to grab something to drink
hey Joey is Never Say Never
hey yeah hey never when you thought
Buffy wasn't gonna come back Never Say
Never
oh it's not laughter we know yeah second
laughter for comedians good game of
Thrones books have been banned from a
prison because they contain maps that
officials worry could be used to escape
against maps city maps and this isn't a
joke but the Logan lucky the bit Logan
lucky one of the funniest bits in any
movie we just play a little bit from
Logan lucky and make that my joke we
thought the rights to it they're where
they're gonna hey those maps aren't
gonna help you through those complicated
plot twists in the last question -
comedy shows and finally Logan director
James Mangold warned that toxic fandom
will scare away talented directors from
nerd movies
Logan makes me think of this and that
makes me think of that
it's a to see thinking you see well not
when you walk through it yeah yeah they
say to think it out loud I I honestly
have zero let's connect can I take that
one right reading that again Logan
director james mangold warned that toxic
fandom would scare away talented
directors from nerd movies that's
interesting be really interested to hear
with an actual talented director Esther
has to say about that James mangled is
great I mean that was good that was
actually a good boy he's a good boy
trivia you get to do organized i as you
guys know i tend to like to just do
these straight because most people don't
actually say any of your handles so i'll
just very easily make everyone sit here
as we say thank you to our host sam
basher at sam basher Erik Bosse a ta vas
Phillip Molina at fimo DJ Wooldridge at
DJ talks trash comment down below
tweet at said new rock stars like this
video for sure share it around and
subscribe to new rock stars for deep
dives and the stuff you love see you
next week bye